a través de un comunicado emitido por la
cancillería del gobierno de Nicolás
maduro dijo haber tomado nota de las
deliberaciones que se llevaron a cabo en
esta conferencia en Bogotá e insistió en
el levantamiento de todas las sanciones
que pesan sobre Venezuela reclaman una
vez más la liberación de los activos de
Venezuela en el extranjero insisten en
que la reanudación del diálogo con la
oposición pasa por la liberación de ese
fondo social acordado en México en
noviembre del año pasado equivalente a
unos 3.000 millones de dólares insisten
además en la liberación del empresario
colombiano Alexa detenido en Estados
Unidos tras ser acusado de lavado de
dinero la plataforma unitaria de la
oposición también emitió un comunicado
en el que insisten en la liberación de
los presos políticos celebran que haya
consenso en que se debe reanudar el
diálogo y exigen una vez más un
cronograma electoral que permita
elecciones libres y transparentes en
Venezuela y que se siguen las
recomendaciones de la emisión de
observación de la Unión Europea en el
comunicado Proponen además la creación
de un grupo de amigos que sirvan Como
garantes de que se cumplan Los acuerdos
recordemos que hay otra parte de la
oposición que no tenía mayores
expectativas en esta conferencia
realizarse en Bogotá no se sentían
representados y aseguraban que el
presidente de Colombia Gustavo Petro no
era un mediador Imparcial sino por el
contrario representaba los intereses de
Nicolás maduro